oh we got beautiful skies out there
those cheese balls did look good and it
is going to be a great week now today
will be pretty much where we were for
the weekend so kiddos this morning you
do need some jackets on we've got an
average of 38 degrees as you're heading
out the door but the afternoon looks
great that bell ringing at 64 for the
afternoon i think you're going to enjoy
that it's going to be a nice afternoon
for school and getting home and playing
outside but even better as we get
through the week oh my goodness so 64
today just a little bit above the norm
of 61 and records are in the 70s for
this time in february and we're going to
be a lot closer to the records than the
average highs
so that sunrise now a little after 6 30
in the morning so we've got a lot of
good sunshine coming our way sunny skies
with high pressure all week gusty north
winds along the colorado river valley
and we've already had those up around 30
miles an hour overnight and early this
morning we'll keep them no wind advisory
but kind of bumpy highs will warm to the
70s starting tomorrow and that means
mornings will get up in the upper 40s to
near 50 degrees much much milder than
what we've had lately it's all thanks to
this high pressure which is building
over the west and even out into the
eastern pacific good sunshine so very
mild conditions and again wind along the
valley the colorado river valley but for
the las vegas valley i think winds
mostly will stay on the light side can't
complain about 64 in february but what
about 72 to 74
as we get through the rest of the week
and things don't change we jump into the
70s tomorrow and we don't look back all
the way through valentine's day next
week again those super mild mornings too
man is that going to feel nice get those
short sleeves out all right